tell them sit down sit down
[Music]
hey everyone its Peter Brown reading for
Seth Macy for his review of NBA 2k 18
NBA 2k 18 is a hardcore sport simulation
if you want to get good you have to put
the work in fortunately there are plenty
of ways to improve your skills no matter
how you want to play and the fact that
there's so much to do is a bonus because
on the court NBA 2k 18 is also an
amazingly well-crafted experience the
first thing that strikes you is how it
looks and feels like a real-life
professional basketball game
now the 2k series attention to detail
has always been incredible and this year
is the best yet using the default camera
it's almost hard to discern between the
game and actual NBA broadcast very
commentary and 3-way chemistry of Ernie
Johnson Kenny Smith and Shaquille O'Neal
during halftime make it feel like a
Thursday night ball game on TNT an
opener for a couple of teams thank you
all for tuning in so happy you're here I
just am ecstatic that you're here I'm
true and I'm really happy that Kenny
Shaq or I'm gonna shoot you or thank you
now of course NBA 2k 18 is also on in
tendo's less powerful switch but don't
discount that version it still looks
great for what it is even if it falls
short of its bigger brothers of course
there's the added bonus of playing in
portable mode which also helps diminish
graphical flaws given the switches small
screen NBA 2k 18s controls remain
largely the same since the introduction
of the pro stick setup in NBA 2k14
movement is handled with the left stick
and the right stick controls things like
shooting where you finish your layups in
ball handler alternatively buttons can
also be used to pass and shoot so if you
don't like shooting with a stick you
don't have to but the stick controls are
satisfying especially when you cross
over your defender and drive to the hoop
for a layup you feel like the ball is
completely in your control thankfully
there is a great way to learn everything
you need to know through 2k you this
tutorial in training mode lets you learn
everything from bounce passes to screen
plays it's very robust with freestyle
and scrimmage options and is super
helpful in perfecting your game without
having to rack up losses in one of the
other modes
Anthony kicks to Western
that one Falls coming off Anthony's feet
16 points for Russell Westbrook and
they're getting their points now almost
exclusively from the triple but this
year's big hook is the expanded my
career the story driven create a player
mode with the new neighborhood central
hub pick your position favorite team and
then tweak the look of your player
before the story begins my career starts
off with a street ball tournament where
you were trying to prove your worth to
team Scouts it has the same teammate
ranking system as in past years we are
grade with your team goes up or down
depending on your performance outside of
the court my career has a fairly typical
rags to riches story with you guiding
your player from unknown rookie too much
hype superstar when you aren't playing
you're in the neighborhood a new
addition that lets you wander around a
few city blocks playing games practicing
buying clothes and shoes and more it
almost feels like an MMO when you first
drop in you're surrounded by other 2k 18
players and their avatars wandering
around your neighborhood and working on
achieving the ultimate 99 overall rating
known as OVR there are two general ways
you can climb your player to the highest
NBA 2k 18 heights you can train play and
practice or you can just spend a bunch
of virtual currency and skirt the whole
thing a 99 OVR puts your player on par
with LeBron James Magic Johnson and
perhaps the greatest player to ever play
the game Michael Jordan but getting
there requires an enormous amount of
work how do you feel about another run I
feel great about another run you're
tired no sure yes sir absolutely
positive yep never put you in this game
you tell me you're tired imma be upset
because you just told me you weren't I
understood I mean I can find another guy
it's enough I'm your guy coach good I
want to see you again starters hey guys
over here
there's a gym of excuse me a Gatorade
power center in the neighborhood that
lets you build up levels and experience
towards badges increasing your next OVR
level the minigames in the gym are
exceptionally unfun just starting a
minigame takes longer than actually
playing one as your character shakes
their arms and gets into place in an
excruciatingly unskipable animation each
and every time you do any of the
workouts only there are a better way to
build up your over yarn boost levels
right microtransactions normally you
build up VC by playing games in my
career which is standard 2k fare but the
amount of VC and experience you earn
feels miniscule even during sessions
where you play at the top of your game
in past years VC flowed more freely so
buying VC with real money feels almost
like an
Ceri evil the game is too stingy with
paying you and VC which makes earning
enough to advance your character along
and Lonesome hill to climb the past
iterations would reward skill players
with difficulty multipliers NBA 2k 18
does away with all that you can increase
your earnings by having a great game you
know making baskets sticking to your
defensive assignment and generally
playing well but there's no reward for
playing at a higher difficulty it's not
just stats that cry out for virtual
currency either shoes shirts tattoos
even haircuts require that you spend VC
with 2k 18 spending your real-world
money feels like the only reasonable way
to get VC as earning it in the game is
quite arduous it's impossible to ignore
how much easier it is to break out your
credit card than to play your way to the
top it's the difference between walking
miles to work or hiring an uber 30-point
games that game right there to fight an
entire basketball is a way of life and
each year NBA 2k is a big part of the
cultural movement real NBA players worry
about their NBA 2k ratings this year's
entry is incredible in so many ways from
its graphics to soundtrack to the
different modes and ways to play hoops
it becomes early on the fastest and
easiest way to progress is by spending
real money though marring an otherwise
tremendous experience
[Applause]
[Music]